an emergence of the tick tockification
of all social media we are shifting in a
massive and I mean massive shift in the
way that we all grew up with social
media in the last decade
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
dailyvee what's good really good day
about meetings our meetings our meetings
daily be hacked 15-minute meetings way
too many of you are doing 30 45 in an
hour when the whole meeting takes 15. I
literally 9 to 9 15 9 15 to 9 30. 9 30
to 9 40.
foreign
tell me about this proposal so with this
proposal it's actually not for you Gary
it's actually for her
yeah the proposal is for you
yeah
so with this what not only are you my
best friend but you're also not only the
woman of my dreams but the love of my
life will you marry me Sophie
oh
really
oh my God
[Applause]
this is still shocking on thank you
thank you thank you
congratulations I know you're probably
pretty shook
what this is crazy
oh yeah
we have so much stuff that comes and
there's so much stuff that I have and I
just want to have fun like surprising
Delight was like the big theory of the
thank you economy like I used to send
people like cheeseburgers and like all
this fun stuff like you literally
somebody's like I'm hungry like what do
you want he's like Burgers I like it's
literally sent some guy in Wyoming or
something a bird like I want to have
more fun
and I want to do more special things for
my audience and so the major hypothesis
is team Gary finds Pockets when I have
like seven minutes like this which is
rare comes with a box we look around
everything that I have because there's
always [ __ ] and then me just throwing
stuff like filming it
throwing and then posting like it's
Mystery Box time click the bio and read
the blog post explaining what mystery
box are is a big new thing
all right take it away I'm so excited
right now you good man okay you looking
good yeah
sleeping seven eight hours a day lightly
you know flat tire on the west side I
live out here trying to get by always
say yes to random [ __ ] I met with mumbot
Jade an artist in a world of how busy I
am my admins are like are you sure are
you Shorty Short yes good Karma's good
she's an up-and-coming artist she's
wonderful she came into the city the 15
minutes meant a ton to her that's
flattering as [ __ ] to me you're putting
Karma into the world and you never know
what you get out of it a conversation
could lead to a thought way too many of
you are overvaluing your time from a
place of ego and not valuing others and
valuing Serendipity and valuing the
power of [ __ ] humility I take
meetings that don't make sense sometimes
even though I'm busy as [ __ ] because you
never know when your kindness leads to
an Insight you never know when your
kindness leads to an Insight my dude
it's garyvee how are you
too good my man you know we're real
serious at Vayner Sports about who we
reach out to because I got a big profile
and I don't want to associate with
people that
are gonna drag me down and
we just think you're a good kid and I
don't even have to speak about football
you already know what you are so you
know very simply
would be very interested in conversating
and see if we have some interest I'd
love to tell you everything that I'm
doing and we're doing but we're building
the fastest growing agency in the game
I'm just very humbled that you reached
out and loved to chop up a little bit
how are you mate
it's great to see you
I'm off to uh one of my friend Ben Lear
has a big uh venture capitalist firm he
was a investor and be friends so I'm
heading to his like big company off-site
doing a fireside chat for him
in Brooklyn and then they'll go back to
the office and got [ __ ] to do been busy
day how about you anything I can do for
you my brother I'm excited that we're
keeping these you know tens and 15s and
don't wait for them don't say okay we
exactly if we spoke now and you're like
oh well I'll see him for 10 minutes 10
minutes in December is 10 minutes
10 minutes way too many of you are like
how do you get so much done by having
15-minute meetings when everybody else
is having an hour for the same
productivity
[Music]
went to Lair Adventures off site that
was a lot of fun got to talk to a bunch
of incredibly well-funded VC backed
smart entrepreneurs
a blockchain that is a scaled
decentralized Ledger that is not
manipulatable is a technology that has
the clear ability to do for transactions
what the internet did for communication
what advice
and an emergence of the tick
tockification of all social media we are
shifting in a massive and I mean massive
shift in the way that we all grew up
with social media in the last decade it
is literally going inverse from a math
CAC LTV first mentality that has
some
commoditized slash Intrigue in the
creative to a creative first affirmation
from consumer interest then deploying
math model creative art
and deep segmentation work and creative
that is relevant for many different
segmentations to create consideration to
sell your thing let the algorithm
work what it does for its own
self-interest that gives you insights to
what creative is actually resonating
then refurbish that creative to
something I call Brand formats and allow
the media to play after you confirmed
the creative because you posted it
organically and got the insights both
Quant and quality
yeah
my boys doing good I wanna see don't go
farther
I hope they understood that I was just
trying to move Smarter on the woods
hope I have a baby boy first I really
want no daughter
that was a good day a bunch of meetings
upstairs going to listen to some music
that's gonna be coming out next year
Business Development going to another
drinks meeting with a buddy from
Australia to do some business
development around IP just grinding
enjoying the process like always miss
you leave a comment what else do you
want from me on dailyvee
before I step my foot in the booth I
asked bro with an narcotics